[Music]
welcome everyone my name is julianne
i'm an admissions officer here at the
stanford graduate school of business
mba program and i'm thrilled to get
to talk to you today hear your questions
and most importantly connect you with
our alumni who
can share their experiences about
applying to the gsb
attending the dsp and their lives after
the gsb
here's just an overview of our session
today so we're primarily spending our
time with our panelists
we're going to just do a brief
introduction but we have just about
an hour just under an hour together our
panelists will introduce themselves so
think of what you might want to say i'll
give a few warm-up questions but
really this session is about answering
your questions so again thinking using
the q a function and submitting your
questions that i will read out to our
panelists and they'll
answer um all right now
just to ground us a bit in the mba
experience and the stanford experience
the stanford experience really focuses
on your journey
your aspirations your goals and
there are many many unique perspectives
that are represented in the class so
here highlighted on the screen
just from the class of 2022 so the
current
students are you know rising to their
second year we have
89 different u.s educational
institutions represented 55 who come
from non-us
educational backgrounds a couple other
highlights here nine percent are the
first in their family
to earn a four-year bachelor's degree
we've got 291 organizations represented
for those
entering the class before their mba and
for 436 students they're all coming from
different journeys and today i hope we
can
give you the confidence as you approach
the application process it looks like
most of you will be applying this
upcoming year
so as you're thinking about your
application preparing the materials
and preparing you know the experiences
you want to highlight i hope we can give
you that confidence to talk about your
experiences in a way that feels
authentic
and real to you so
without further ado i am going to move
into our
panelists so i've got just a slide here
prepared
um just some brief background
information for each of us
um and so i know we've got three on the
line so far i may have one other joining
us later on in the call
but um i'd love for each of our
panelists to introduce yourselves and in
your own words maybe give us a little
bit of background about
your journey prior to the dsb so maybe
what propelled you to pursue a
an mba from stanford um and maybe a
little bit about your industry
experience
and then i will pose some softball
questions like why an mba why stanford
to get us started
while the questions come in so maybe
we'll start
annalise do you want to kick us off and
then from the side we'll move
uh just the right so those who are
further out from the gsb experience
sure thing thank you for having me um so
my name is annaliese
and my background is in um
d2c startups i worked in operations
um i did that right after undergrad
and i knew pretty much graduating from
um
college that i would probably eventually
pursue an mba
um i graduated in 2011 when we were
starting to use words like retail
apocalypse
and it seemed to me like the companies
that were going to come out about okay
were going to be led by very agile and
forward-thinking leaders
um so it was important to me to
eventually really expand
my my horizons and uh stanford was
obviously a great place to do that
um and yeah since uh
business school i have continued to work
in the startup space but i'm now doing
consulting
um with d2c startups and i'm focusing on
analytics for them
awesome hi everyone my name is
friendship fawaya um class
also annalise and erin same class hi
annelise um
so i started out my career i was always
in cpg but i was in research and
development
i'm starting off at procter and gamble
and then moving off to the keller
company
um so my reason for switching was i
wanted to be more
in a business role so more i'm currently
in marketing at pepperidge farm
but i wanted to be more the forefront of
a lot of decision making
strategy um direction for the companies
that i was working at so that's
primarily why i went back in
and got an mba um i've been at pepper's
farm
for the last four years but happy to be
here thanks for having me
okay leslie hi hey i'm leslie ammon's
birthday i am
a gsb 2012. i'm so excited to be here
um my non-traditional route to the gsb
started
actually well it started maybe a little
bit more what we'd call traditional at
least back then
um in investment banking so i started
out as an
investment banking analyst but then um
went over in industry so shout out to
all my retail and fashion people out
there
saw some people um in the chat so i
worked at
ralph lauren and ralph lauren
was an amazing experience for me i
worked in fpna there
so finance was kind of my foot in the
door but i always say that
you know opening up excel was sort of
where the synergies
started and ended um but it was amazing
to work there and
and um get to know all aspects of the
business and so
you know why did i i say that that's
where i developed my passion for fashion
and just
so it's had such a great experience
there and
ultimately decided to pursue an mba
because
um i'll be honest when i first thought
about it i didn't think that i'd
necessarily
need the mba for you know my next job i
think it was a deeply personal decision
for me i needed some time and i wanted
to retool i had
gone to a business undergrad uh
school where i thought you know mark i
wanted to go into marketing and
and at the time for undergrad i just
wasn't i thought marketing was one thing
and it turns out it wasn't another and
then after four years in the workforce i
you know thought well let me go back to
that marketing thing which i thought was
soft before but it definitely is not and
so i needed some
a means to retool and think about what i
wanted to do
going forward and think about that
career switch and i thought well
you know an mba might not help me
immediately but you know hopefully in
five to ten years when i'm looking at
senior leadership positions
um it'll help me and i share that
anecdote because it couldn't have been
further from the truth
right like um my mba has been so helpful
it's been so wonderful to me both
personally and professionally but i
don't know
having kind of a non-traditional route
that's was an assumption that i made
going in that ended up not being right
but i'm so happy that i did ultimately
decide to pursue my mba
and ended up getting my dream job in
fashion
afterwards um turns out i drank a little
the kool-aid at
the gsb and ended up going more the
startup route
and uh worked in you know sort of a cpg
retail sort of um company for a while
and now find myself in the wellness
space at goodrx
fantastic thank you all for being so
thorough with your motivations i mean
what a clear way to state your reasons
early on about thinking about the mba
i'm actually going to stop sharing my
screen so that we can
see our faces um more prominently and
this is the portion again where i'd
really encourage uh those on the call
to put in your questions in the q a
function and there's a little thumbs up
where you can upload a question so if
someone else has a similar question as
you
uh please use that so it'll bump it to
the top for me so i can see it more
easily
and we actually already have one
question and it's coming from catherine
and this is going to echo something i
wanted to
start us off with too question focuses
around
experiencing imposter syndrome and how
you may have dealt with it while the gsb
and i think another tangent to that um
that i would like to pose to the group
is
were there any myths or rumors or
um maybe some hesitations you may have
encountered thinking about pursuing an
mba coming
from an industry that maybe wasn't
always
nudging you in that direction or maybe
trying to explain to others why you were
pursuing this mba so
whether you want to tackle the
admissions side of it or your experience
at the gsb with the imposter syndrome um
either facet i'd love for you to
elaborate on
and you don't all have to answer but
whoever this question speaks to
yeah i'll jump in i'll say you know i
that that that question can be asked in
a number of different ways or
you know lenses on it but my
interpretation is you know having a
non-traditional
background um you know coming in and and
doing the more traditional business
thing i
i definitely had peers um who
what do you call it's like poets versus
quants type thing
um but i'll say you know i i don't want
to say no
i mean i i have i still have imposter
syndrome like all the time but um
but um i i'd say
the one take away i'll give you i know
we don't have a a ton of time is that
you're not alone
and that was my main takeaway there
right so it's like
you know you are special and unique
don't get me wrong
um but one of the most amazing things
about my personal experience at the gsb
was that there were so many special and
unique people i had this
opportunity that i had like i i'm
definitely in the non-traditional
background like category immediately but
i had sort of a finance background so i
kind of like
was in both lanes um but you see that
you know one of the reasons that i know
we'll probably get to this later that i
loved the gsb and why i ultimately
decided to go there was because
um you can you can tailor your
curriculum to
you know what you know or what you don't
know so like i remember accounting i had
taken accounting class before
um and you know but but here you could
take i forget what the different levels
are but
basically it's tailored to you know your
experience so if you've never taken
an accounting class or finance or you
know maybe your imposter syndrome has to
do with like some other aspect of it
there are tons of people who are there
with you and they're there to support
you and i found that
everyone was was really supportive of
each other so you can rest assured that
you're never going to be the only one
and you kind of get bonded
in that and that we all have you know
different backgrounds and i think that's
why even people
traditional non-traditional whatever it
is people come to the gsb because they
love the diversity of backgrounds and
that's really ultimately
not answering the question but that's
what really helped me stand out you know
i wanted to do things in retail and
fashion and
and there were other people but i was
able to also be a big fish in a small
pond and people
you know they may they maybe didn't come
to me for you know accounting work
um but they did come to me you know when
they were doing some sort of marketing
project or um whatever it was those are
maybe bad examples but everyone has
something unique to offer and i found
that the gsb experience was really
well-rounded so everyone had a chance to
kind of stand out
yeah thank you and then we do have what
leslie's talking about we have several
levels of
um experience i'll say for certain
core required courses like finance for
example some of you
of your classmates will be coming in
with years of experience in finance and
working really in depth in that field
and others will have never taken a
finance class before so we've got the
basic level
accelerated and advanced so that
everyone is still learning and
progressing but
also you're able to kind of pick up some
of those skills if you haven't had it
previously and there's a couple other
um classes that follow that same
trajectory
uh annalise or food show is there
anything you wanted to add to that
or i can move on to other questions um
yeah i'll just
um totally agree with a lot of what
leslie
shared i think you do come in with this
impression that you're so
when you're coming from a
non-traditional you're pretty unique
you're coming to a class where there are
a lot of people who are like consultants
or
from investment banking or finance um
but what i found is
there are a lot of other people who have
different experiences like they're
coming from government public shelter
stem sector i have some classmates who
had been teaching in the past like a
charter school so you're not
alone um so there's that sense of that
community
but then part of the imposter syndrome
is this feeling of like what is it that
i
uniquely bring um you know so as you're
thinking through your application
or when you're evaluating options it's
like what is it that's really unique
about me like one thing that i
i think for better or worse was great
about my background was i used to make
pop tarts
for those who may not be familiar
they're like these like baked pastries
um and that was my job and that was like
people who lost their minds in
business school when they found that
that's what i used to do for a living
and it does give you a different
perspective that you're
and that's the reason that you're in the
class um so i say like
yes imposter syndrome 100 but keeping in
mind like what makes you unique and what
you're bringing to the class
helps sort of balance that out
um same vein and this can be a very
quick
answer because i do think some of this
is accounted for in the admissions
process but
did you ever have to feel you needed to
prove your quantitative experience when
you came from a non-traditional
background so i'll say on the admission
side there are some basic requirements
and if you
we're if we're concerned you may not
have the quantitative skills we'll let
you know before you're admitted and
encourage you to take a class before you
come so
um i wouldn't worry about that sense but
once you're there for those of you i
don't know all of your majors but if you
didn't have maybe a deep quantitative
knowledge
you have to prove it once you were there
or did you find that you were able to
kind of
you know pick up the curriculum pretty
quickly and find support from your
classmates
i was a history major so i'm happy i'm
perfect
um i found that the amount of group work
that there was was very
helpful in terms of you know getting
stuff
across the finish line um you know the
first
especially quarter is very heavy with
the sort of required core classes which
can be more
quantitative um but again
uh to echo everyone said like you are
not alone and then
um the fact that you are put in groups
with people to
figure out date and decisions or
accounting
you end up with enough of working
knowledge of it um and it is
it's challenging work but it never feels
like um
you're isolated as a non-traditional
person who can't keep up
um everyone's in it together
yeah and so there's actually another
question in the similar vein but not
about academics
did you feel like you had to have more
work experience than maybe a typical
student prior to business school to make
up for
a cpg or retail background
i did not um no yeah
i don't know work experience yeah i
don't
i'm trying to i i don't think it was
really an issue
i think obviously there are you know
younger people or
people who have more work experience and
it comes out in
that way but i wouldn't say it was a
limiting factor or something when it
when it came to academics
yeah i would say i mean i was on the
higher end i had five years of
experience before i went to the gsv
um but i would say it's more about the
caliber of the experiences you have and
um the breadth and the depth of those
experiences versus the
calendar length of them
and also your willingness to uh speak up
and participate and be able to react to
a case
um occasionally there's someone who
there'll be a case and strategy and like
they're like oh i worked at that company
and good for them but
if you can still think about it
critically then
you're fine yeah so annelise could you
elaborate on that cause there's actually
a question about what was it like
interacting with people who came from
more traditional backgrounds like
consulting or finance
um were there skills that you were able
to bring to the table that they didn't
have and vice versa
um you know i remembering that first
quarter um
where there were it's more traditional
it feels like in the
academic workload um but then after a
bit when people
get to know you and understand what your
strengths are i guarantee you
someone will reach out for a coffee
check cause they have this idea to
manufacture hawaiian shirts and they
really want to know how you did it
and that stuff happens all the time um
and then you find the retail club
and or cpg groups and um
find you know core people who have
shared experiences that way too
i love that example because hawaiian
shirts you're like what i'm selling
hawaiian shirts how is that even and
it's like yeah someone might want to
start a hawaiian shirt company and i'd
say
you know no matter what you're doing
right now and you know assuming you have
a little bit of experience
you know you're a practitioner of
something and you know not to diss my
my friends and i was a banker too not to
uh
diss my friends in finance and
consulting but like all of their
experience is very outside looking in
you know
like these are the recommendations and
this is you know the strategy but they
don't have the execution experience and
so obviously a
really amazing experience but you know
if you're
it doesn't matter what you're doing but
you're doing something outside of that
you're actually building something and
you're a practitioner you have an
expertise
no matter what it is that's really
really valuable and i wouldn't discount
that
yes very well said um so
leslie you just mentioned
recommendations this kind of touches on
another question here it's open to
anybody but how did you navigate
uh your career development conversations
or the application process with your
managers
from your pre-mba jobs in a field that
maybe it's not as common for folks to
get an mba
so was there any tension or explaining
or was it
you know supportive and go ahead right
from the start could you talk a little
bit about that
yeah i can i can start so it's not
it's not super common so in my before i
went to business school i was a food
scientist
um at kellogg's so back to my point
about making pop tarts in the lab
um and so it's not pretty common people
have masters
phds i think i knew somebody who had a
phd in serial chemistry i didn't even
know
that was the thing wow um so people are
very much
applied and specialized especially in
the sciences
and so maybe you've got one or two
people who had mbas and those were
people who were
vps or very much in senior leadership
within the
research and development function um so
i think it was really because i wanted
to make this switch
so totally if you're trying to stay in
this it depends on what track you're on
and if you
are in a technical role and you want to
be more of a senior leader
or a manager or manager of people um so
my leadership obviously felt like made
sole sense to her because she had an mba
but she had remained in the same
function
but because my career aspirations had
been more to switch over to brand
management and marketing function
that really was something that i felt
that i needed to get like a broader
view of of what's happening from a
business perspective really developed my
business acumen because most of my
experiences had been very execution
oriented but very much focused on food
development
um so it was definitely made sense
because i showed what that transition
was going to be where i
ultimately wanted to be um and had a lot
of support i didn't return to kellogg
but
there was a lot of support for me to do
that because they could really see from
the career development where i was
trying to go
yeah i had a mixed bag you know i think
you know
and i luckily i had my direct manager
was
was very supportive of me in general
i'll be honest you know
i was i was there was a lot of
skepticism i don't think it was
negative per se but like why would you
want to do that but
when they found out um some of the
schools i was applying to they kind of
got it um you know stanford has a lot of
cachet so they're like oh stanford okay
um but even even then you know some
people
i'll just prepare some people weren't
that supportive like you know i really
i asked someone for a recommendation and
he acted like he would support me and
i just never heard from him again like
in that sense right i would go to
meetings with him it was my boss's boss
it would have been
really awesome to have a recommendation
i thought you know i've done
extremely good work for this person and
um
it was very clear to me by the end and
then someone else said well you know
um you realize if we have layoffs you'll
be the first to go like that was just
not a helpful
right uh comment and i kind of just took
it in stride but i had enough
people in my corner who were rooting for
me and who kind of got it
that it was okay but there was a little
bit of an explanation sometimes
thank you both for sharing that um
there's a lot of questions coming up now
about
post-gsb so um could you
talk about the school's resources um
for non-traditional backgrounds um
now i'm not sure what directions me but
talking about like the career search the
network so maybe some of the
opportunities i know there's a couple
questions also about
clubs on campus that you know just
looking at our website there might not
be that some that are particularly
focused on cpg or brand management so
could you talk a little bit maybe about
the resources in terms of the career
management center maybe
pivoting industries as well as some of
the social
student clubs and organizations that may
have supported your
experience at the gsb and then maybe
post gsb bulls as well
i can jump it so i loved so i kind of
alluded to this thing
when i said big fish in a small pond so
you know you're definitely not alone
there will be at least one other person
but i was
you know at the time my year you know i
was
all in on fashion and retail and gung-ho
and i
i thought it was i thought stanford was
an especially great place to be
because things like and this isn't you
know
you know never say anything about other
schools but i had
i had i remember there was like a retail
trek that had come to san francisco from
a different well-known school they were
so nice and invited us and i was the
only one from
um stanford who went and they were
having elections in their retail club
and i remember it was just
so competitive like they were so
obsessed it was so funny because
my experience was that there was a
retail club at stanford
but i just kind of revived it i was like
i want to run for president and it was
like no problem whatsoever
and so it was really nice and so there
are a lot of resources obviously
from classmates or classes or whatnot
but
a lot of these extra curriculars and
stuff like you can
use the fact that you're unique to your
advantage because
you know a different broad thing no
matter what your background is
is having that.edu address right like
while you're a student you can get
away with anything so my story with
being the president of the retail club
was i was
i there we i don't know if they still
have the luxury track well i mean
the past year has been crazy okay you're
shaking your head so
i went on the lux track my first year it
was amazing and so then i'm like i'm
president of the retail club like signed
up
so in the second year i'm like oh my god
i have to lead a group of my classmates
to you know france what am i going to do
and all of a sudden i start i just start
emailing the ceos of like hermes
and louis vuitton and gucci and i'm just
like
hi i'm a student at the gsb blah blah
you wouldn't
you'd be amazed like i would instantly
get forwarded to like
their assistant or this or like we would
love to host
stanford students here and so i'll just
say like if you look at it through that
lens like
you know obviously the community and
everyone on campus is really supportive
but don't
discount just you know being in school
in general having that
edu they know that i don't want anything
i'm not necessarily asking them for a
job
and you can get away with a lot of
different things and a lot of doors open
while you're there by just being able to
reach out and say like hey i'm president
of this club so even if it's not like
the most robust club on campus um
you know the affiliation and reaching
out like it'll just open
up a lot of doors that will create a lot
of opportunities for you in my
experience
yeah and i can talk from like a career
management center the cmc
because related to the question about
imposter syndrome
i had this in my mind that even though i
had been in cbg for
five years before i went to the business
school it would be really hard for me to
get a marketing job
so it would be really difficult for me
to make the switch um so i spent a lot
of time in the cmc
and um one of the coaches so they have
different coaches for different
industries so there are a couple coaches
for cpg
specifically so you definitely have
somebody who has experience who
knows some companies from a recruiting
standpoint and those alumni who are at
these companies
um so i was working with a particular
coach and she just really helped like i
think it was a lot of
addressing the imposter syndrome of like
how am i supposed to get any of these
jobs like i've never worked marketing
and
i have no idea what i'm doing but really
starting to ground on what my
experiences are and what are some of the
connections
um sort of the similar the common
threads between my past experiences and
what i'm trying to do in the future
so huge amount of support for folks who
are
coming from traditional backgrounds to
the career management center i will say
i was heading i co-chaired the marketing
club when i was there
um so we did have it at the time when i
was in school i know that
seems like eons ago at this point but um
you know leading treks
i'm going to visit companies in the bay
area that had a focus on cpg
and we even hosted like a super bowl
session where we reviewed ads
um and just talked about those
experiences but even if it's
not there right now i think back to
leslie's point like you
have the lead way you have the freedom
that's one of the things i loved about
stanford it's like if it doesn't exist
you can totally create it and people
will support you
that's very well said if it's not there
you can you can create it or build it
um so we've got again some more career
questions
um and actually from both sides of
of the posty experience there are people
who'd like to announce maybe
uh when show this might be for you how
did the mba help you grow or get your
career goals within the cpg community
and then wrestling and elise um did how
did it
was it easy to pivot or make a change or
kind of move into a new industry
with the mba um did you feel like your
background in retail retailer cpg were
helpful in your post mba role so
whichever order you all want to speak
into but maybe
kind of that that connection between the
nba experience and your career goals as
well as your
pre-mba experience and now your post mba
career
yeah i can um i think for me
it it definitely like as i was connected
to what i was saying
earlier i think starting with some of
the experiences you have so even though
i had been in research and development i
had a lot of exposure to
you know i worked cross-functionally
with people from marketing people from
insights
so i already started to build sort of
those connections early on
um and so when i moved and i started
working i had a couple marketing
internships before i went to pepperwood
farm full-time
um i really started to lean on my prior
experiences so
you know collaboration skills like
getting people together
building your vision or things that were
already
skilled i had developed from my prior
life so just started there
um and i think you're looked on as
someone who has a very unique experience
like even today
even though i'm surrounded by people who
have mbas
i have a very different perspective from
somebody who was
a marketing undergrad or somebody who
had worked for like an
agency um so there's something very
unique about the perspective that i
bring coming from a different function
or just having a different set of
experiences that helps me so much
because i think that's what's made me
stand out
um in the past like four years of my
career so i would say
you know it's one of a leaning on some
of the past experiences that you have
and not being shy about that because
it's probably why they hired you is not
just because you have an mba but because
you're bringing something that's unique
and interesting but i think what i
gained from the mba was more of just
sort of
more social more soft like i always i
mean sure you can learn about
a lot of what i learned about for
marketing was on the job
um in terms of just like pulling reports
like look
understanding what's happening from a
trend perspective i took some really
awesome classes
at the gsb that built our foundation but
some of the more competency things the
things you can learn on the job but i
think what i really loved about the gsb
was
more of those interpersonal dynamics how
are you working with people
especially when you're becoming more in
positions of leadership
influencing with authority or without
authority authority
um more importantly so i think those
were some things i really
learned um or developed at the gsb
and continue to apply in addition to
some of my core
skills from my prior life
thank you um
i think my my perspective on
translating the gsb experience is that
the amount of
introspection that the gsb affords you
is a really special opportunity
um and those the soft skills that the
french referenced
um and i think i've
viewed my career starting with you know
the mba internship through now as sort
of a series of hypotheses to test
so i came from small companies and i was
like okay for my internship i'll try a
really big company and then
maybe that wasn't quite what i wanted so
make different changes
along the way um and i think
it's also given me a lot of confidence
to
you know even though i don't have the
edu email address anymore to
still like reach out and make those um
asks for career advice or help or
you know i was pretty sure that i wanted
to start working analytics so
i got a couple of my classmates who have
a startup to let me do a project for
them and just
like get some real world experience um
testing that out even that was just a
year ago um
so the the community is is really there
for you
um there's some questions now actually
this should be a fun topic can you talk
about the global experience
so your time and i think back to when
your student when we're still traveling
and hopefully
travel will resume this upcoming year
but um
did you do a global experience and which
one
and what did you learn from it
i did a global experience it was so much
fun
i kind of chuckled because of course you
learn it's amazing it's an amazing
addition to the gsb curriculum but i
thought
learn i had so much fun um
but yeah no i mean i think just broader
so
i went to um um
oh my god where'd i go thailand in
vietnam
and then afterwards yeah i went to
cambodia with some people um because we
were just not
done with the travels and then ended up
going to a personal wedding in india but
anyways it was it was amazing and i i
look back on those times and those
pictures and to
just be in those countries and visit you
know obviously there's the cultural
aspects and whatnot but um
also just have the opportunity to to see
how business is done in other countries
was invaluable
it's not um i would say more on a
personal level for me i mean
um you know i don't on a daily basis now
necessarily do business in vietnam but
it was it was just like a fun
um educational personal
experience for me and i'll just do a
quick plug for just you know
hopefully we'll be out of these global
pandemic times soon and
just how much the travel at gsb just in
general meant
to me and um you know the bonding that
you have with your classmates and
whatnot was just really
awesome if you can i would just really
recommend that people take advantage of
that as much they
as much as they can because now uh
post gsb three kids and uh getting
getting that time is
i'll never get it back so let's say you
did a
little study trip then yes sorry
long-winded way i did a global study
trip
yeah um and i had
a couple so i had a global study trip
before
when i started they were trying this new
thing where you would do it before you
even went
sorry there's like a plane in your head
it's ready to pass
yeah we're telling those the seminars
global seminars it happens like
i think a couple weeks before classes
officially start okay
there he goes um so
we can still hear you
circling we'll just see if it goes away
um so
i did a gst to south korea um to seoul
and busan before school started
um and i'm just reading through some of
the questions and i'm definitely like a
uh cpg die hard so not i mean there's
non-tradition and there's like really
non-traditional because i didn't move at
all i like stayed in the same industry
the entire time
so everything i did at the gsb was very
much cpg focused
um so the trip to south korea was about
consumers and consumerism
in asia specifically in south korea
given like the explosion of
consumers there and like technology and
all of that and then i had a
gmix which is a global immersion
experience
um in which is my second internship
where i worked for a company in shanghai
um it was a beverage a food and beverage
company
helping them with some of their
innovations so again
super amazing worked for one um
but as leslie was saying love the
experience of just working in a
different country especially an industry
that i wanted to be in and i always try
to make sure i have international
experiences because
consumers are very different even if
you're selling the same product
and just learning about working in
different cultures like
my internship in shanghai i didn't speak
mandarin um
so that was a very different cultural
experience in terms of how do you get
work done when you don't speak the
language
but those are things you have to be
faced with the business leader in the
future and
how do you navigate that so i was really
grateful to be able to have those
um experiences at the gsb
annelise what about you
um so i did a gst to
new zealand and then a lot of unofficial
travel
and i think that my um
primary takeaway from all of that was
just the quality time spent with people
because
you know each quarter is 10 weeks on
campus and things
just fly by and everyone's moving a
million calls an hour but then all of a
sudden you're
across the world um you know in morocco
with funsha and like
get to hear about the pop tarts um
that sort of that very unique and
special
time with people um learning about your
incredible classmates
was really just incredibly valuable
yeah yeah so you've heard you've heard
about several different types
of global experiences there is a
requirement so everyone who comes to the
gst will do some sort of global
experience
we have the global seminars which start
right before school starts
um global study trips so it seems like
everyone did that and those are actually
typically planned by your classmates
usually second year students will pick
the location and plan out the trip
and then gmix is a sort of a shorter
internship that you might do in an
international location
we also have partnerships um with
universities in china xinhua university
we have an exchange program for a couple
weeks and you know if none of those
appeals to you there's still
you know your individual research
projects so lots of ways to meet that
they have been um sort of retooled in a
virtual space so still ways to connect
um internationally and get that global
experience but
again the hope is still to go back to
travel one day
i'd like to shift now as we're still
talking about the experience itself
there's a couple questions about
favorite classes that you may have taken
on the gsb
and if you want to think about the lens
of
how they may have helped your career but
i know one of you mentioned
interpersonal dynamics and some of the
leadership development courses so
if there's any classes that stand out
that maybe have helped you in your
career
or that were particularly useful in your
industries love to hear about that
um consumer behavior is one obviously
um i wish that was a whole quarter long
class unfortunately i think it's only it
was only half a quarter when i was there
um but beyond that uh i have a very
random spray of favorite classes there
was um
touchy-feely which is interpersonal
dynamics it's
you know well-known for a reason it's
just completely eye-opening and a very
unique experience understanding how
how you um relate to your to your
classmates and how other people perceive
you
um uh di marzo is
short for the advanced corporate
financial modeling
um to mars as a professor and
that's actually uh been quite useful in
my operations and analytics work it's
just a really robust
um modeling class while it's a little
bit
can be a little intimidating it's also
just a safe space to
to just try something um and and learn a
bunch
um and then my last favorite class is uh
policy and politics with keith hennessey
who um
had worked at the white house he's
incredible
and i learned much more about strategy
from him
than the actual strategy class just
understanding
um how the politics of washington work
with
uh just stakeholders and um influence
and i would say agree um totally agree
on consumer behavior by sushi wong um
amazing class like i think i still i
there's
i won't get into it but there was like a
class about making toilet paper black
and i still have that roll of toilet
paper like she gave everyone in the
class the role
and i still have it because just remind
me about being disruptive and like who
would have thought to make toilet paper
black
and just just the concept of thinking
differently
um so that's a class that sticks with me
um i will say
another class is high performance
leadership um
which is you know sort of like touchy
but brought into the workplace in terms
of like how do you interact with people
how do you
create a high-performing team through um
creating a
culture of open feedback and um
just being honest and candid so i think
that's definitely something especially
being in a function where i'm all i do
is work on teams i can't do anything by
myself
um that's been a really really important
class that i took
i'll throw a bogey in there i agree with
everything that was said
so many amazing classes at the gsb um
i remember when i was on the other side
on listening to a panel like this i
remember one of the panelists said
you know i think the one of the final
questions was you know what did you love
about the gsb
or how did it change you or something
and you said you know it's definitely
made me
a better uh business person
or you know whatever we're there we're
there to be professional and whatnot but
it's made me
a better human being and husband and
father in this
um and i thought huh that's a really
i won't say weird there's no judgment
but i was like that's an interesting
thing to say
right like this interesting takeaway so
i'll just add in i took a class called
work and family which is how
was actually so transformative um
i got married during the gsb both me and
my husband were in the same class
actually so
i i asked him made him take it with me
and it's just i'd say
that's one of the classes that continues
to pay dividends for me as well
um as i think you know now that i'm a
mother and thinking about leaning into
the job and what does that mean and how
we manage our household and whatnot
it's just been ingrained in us and it's
something that comes up on a
on a on a weekly if not daily basis for
us and
in terms of um you know how we how the
how the professional plays in with the
personal because both are very important
and that was really transformative to me
those are great i've heard some new
classes on this call today that
haven't come up before that's awesome
thank you um
so we have let's see i want to be
mindful of our time still got
about 10 minutes so that's great um
there's a lot of
energy and uploads around this
particular question
um it says how did you leverage your
unique
background of coming from a
non-traditional role to advocate for
your own success at the gsb
i think you've touched on this in some
ways but if there's anything that comes
to mind about
advocacy or making sure that you're
successful at the gsb
[Music]
um
yeah i'd say i mean um i think two ways
to interpret the question but
i'd say um part of what that meant for
me was just
being clear about which i think there's
another question here about
prioritization and how did you make sure
you were staying keeping in mind of what
your goals were when you were at the gsb
i think because i was so i knew i wanted
to go back into cpg
um it made me really focus and it made
me more intentional about
um like the clubs i was going to or some
of the treks that i was being on or like
the global experiences i was having like
i was certainly and this is n of one
like not everyone is
like this but i was very much focused on
um like how how does this help me become
a better like
i guess better servant of the cpg
industry when i leave the gsp
and being intentional about some of the
activities that i was involved in and i
certainly leaved room i considered
consulting for maybe one quarter
and then changed my mind so i was that
open just open enough
um but i think that was sort of and you
know people sort of knew me as being the
food person
and whenever someone was like thinking
to an analysis point about coffee chats
like some people have been thinking
about opening
starting food businesses and getting an
understanding of like what does it take
um so being really helpful in that way
and just sort of speaking
up in classes and sharing my experience
at the companies i've been in or just a
way to
um sort of show that you know this is
the experience i have um so that's sort
of how i advocated for my experience
when
i was there
um all right so there's a couple
questions um and
you alluded that now you can't do
anything on your own
uh so in cpg would much of the work is
cross-functional
and each person brings a skill set but
the leader of that project might shift
how did you consider and communicate
your past leadership experiences i'm
going to add in
an assumption about this question of at
the application process
so maybe when you're thinking back to
when you're applying um
how did you communicate that leadership
experience um
throughout your application and maybe in
your interview as well
especially when you're coming from maybe
a position of not a formal leadership
role as many folks who are applying from
the gsb are
you may not be in a formal manager or
leadership role but still
you've had leadership experiences in
different ways
so they can ask you to think way back to
when you're applying
and maybe um you know what you recall
about those reflections as you were
applying
i guess i would say lean into the
uniqueness of of your background and
consider that leadership can look like a
lot of different things
and it's not necessarily i led this team
and we consulted and made a 2x2 and
presented the project it can be that you
found insights found new suppliers
brought new perspectives to your company
and and also keep in mind that the gsb
is a place to
to learn and grow into
the leader that you want to become um
so i look well there's a lot that goes
into the application i wouldn't say that
you need to have like
founded a thing and you know completed
your career already like
know that um there's so much still ahead
of you and
that intellectual curiosity is gonna
carry you a long way
it also doesn't have to be at work i
think that was great commentary
um i would also think about the
extracurriculars you do
you know you're not you're a
well-rounded
individual who's more than just the
place you go to work
five or more days a week so what else do
you do in your life where you exhibit
leadership
yeah exactly like your communities that
you're a part of the activities and even
inside your own job there might be
things that are outside of your direct
line of responsibility that
uh you've had influence or you've had
new ideas and been able to
you know get those going too so yeah
thinking broadly i think that both
you have shared great advice as you
think about the different experiences
you've had
um leslie i think this is a question for
you you mentioned at the very beginning
drinking the kool-aid of the startup
culture so could you talk a little bit
about you know with so many
opportunities how did you stay the
course of your goals or how did the gsb
shape those goals
oh good question um let's see my
i guess it's a unique it's not unique to
me but um
yeah i would say i think it was already
mentioned on this call but i think it
was you know an answer to the question
about
um you know how do you advocate for
yourself and it was a really good
question it stumped me because i thought
well i didn't
really need to advocate but i think you
know what was answered is
really rang true to me and that um
you know i i'd encourage you right like
this is a big deal we talked about
leaving your position
telling your you know your team that
you're leaving and you're gonna leave
the workforce and
do this it's a big commitment so i think
one of the things that was most helpful
to me was having a plan ironically i
realized that's not where like that's
ultimately not where i went but i would
say you know just cliff's notes things
that i learned was
the people who came in and said you know
i don't really know what i want to do
but
i'll figure it out in the next two years
i want to say at least in my friend
group 100 of the time they had not
figured it out in two years
because there's just so many pulls on
your time and so many different things
you're doing that
you know so i would say that one of the
things that i did was i just had
you know like was already said like a
very clear plan this is what i've done
this is what i want to do going forward
and it starts with the application
process right like i always joke that
one of the best things and one of the
reasons i knew i wanted to attend
stanford was because
i got smarter during the application
process it was very introspective to me
and forced me to really think about okay
what am i doing what do
i want to do what are the next steps
that you know i'm going to need to go
there so
that influenced you know the trips i
took
it influences the classes i took the
clubs i
joined etc etc and my one huge caveat
with that is that it can change like it
will change
it could it could be a complete 180 but
at least you know you have that north
star so you don't feel like
pulled in a million directions right
we've talked about polls on time and how
there's no time for anything
at least if you have a north star even
if you veer and you go and you
ultimately go south
whatever um you know it it
it it helps you just kind of keep things
together so um
you know that's what i did i think for
me if i'm just completely transparent
i say the best thing about the gsb is
that i got my dream job like it was
great it worked out i wanted to work in
um you know i said i wanted to work at
you know extreme luxury goods and i got
that
i jokingly say that it just that
experience
and this is very personal to me just
ended up not being the dream i thought
by the time i got there i realized that
what i really wanted to get out of
life and what i was really passionate
about had changed
and um you know that's okay too
so i ended up um you know talking to a
classmate of mine who was an investor
and i thought you know all that other
project work i had done during
school where i was working supporting
startups and writing business plans
i kind of want to do that as my career
and so
my classmate made some introductions
to founders in the la area and you know
one of them was looking for you know
their first marketing hire and the rest
is history and so
um but it was really fun like during
school i would always say you know
people would have all these wonderful
business plans and i said well you know
don't you wouldn't you be happy if your
business made 50 million or something
like that and it said that's what each
of these retail stores makes you know
like i'm doing that too i'm being
entrepreneurial which is
so true but um you know i ended up
learning and pivoting and
you know i needed all those experiences
to be part of my journey and
i'm grateful for them yeah that's
yeah captures it so well like we will
not hold you to
what you say you want to do in your
application we know it'll change and you
don't need to know right away
i have an idea you might revision um you
might know very specifically what you
want to do but
i think unless that you've highlighted
that so well that it's going to change
and shift and
you know function like you mentioned
having that focus to help you prioritize
and really curate your own experience is
going to be so helpful
um because who knows what will come out
like you know you might be doing
something totally different at the end
um so we are wrapping up now i do want
to thank our panelists and also offer
you the opportunity if there's anything
else you'd like to add or say before we
all sign off i'm so grateful for you for
spending your time
with us today and sharing your
experiences um but it will
sort of end a bit abruptly so if there's
any final
words or pieces of advice you'd like to
share with the group
before we say goodbye i'll let you do
that now
good luck good luck
all right well thank you three so much
again um i hope for everyone on the call
that this was helpful i know we weren't
able to get to all of the questions so
if there's anything that's still
pressing or still top of mind please
feel free to reach out to our admissions
office
um you know feel free to put my name in
there and your email will get to me
we'll also have plenty of other
admission events throughout the summer
chats with our alumni chats with
students so if you want maybe a more
personal
um or smaller event as well there will
be opportunities for that as well but
i hope this has been inspiring for you i
hope that this gives you the confidence
to approach the application
and share your story share your
experiences and hopefully stanford is a
place that you
you see yourself thriving in and
once again thank you to our panelists
and i will say
so long for now and hope to see you all
at future events